Tom Cruise's Mission should he choose to
accept it boosting his latest
Blockbuster dead reckoning's box office
winnings well he has accepted it but it
might truly be an impossible feat keep
watching to find out the links Cruz is
taking to make sure mi7 hits the biggest
screens possible during the early days
of the covid-19 pandemic Crews made it a
point to ensure that top gun Maverick
the longest dating sequel to Tony
Scott's 80s classic received a
theatrical release sticking to his guns
Cruz Unleashed Maverick on Memorial Day
Weekend 2022 to critical and Commercial
Acclaim with the sequel emerging as the
actor's biggest hit to date thanks to a
1.4 billion dollar Cube not only did
Cruz walk away as the theatrical model
savior but his second outing is Maverick
netted the actor a 100 million dollar
payday per variety further solidifying
his clouds as Hollywood's biggest
a-lister now the actor is set to release
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
1. the seventh film in his Marquee
action franchise expectations are sky
high for the latest Mission outing after
all the actor has to follow-up top gun
Maverick and an extremely stacked summer
lineup with a budget of nearly 300
million dollars as per The Hollywood
Reporter dead reckoning part 1 has a
long way to go before it can boost
profits which is why every dollar counts
unfortunately Cruz's latest mission is
facing an uphill battle thanks to
Christopher Nolan's Oppenheimer
according to the outlet Puck Cruz is
reportedly upset that mission impossible
dead reckoning part 1 will lose its IMAX
screens to Oppenheimer when the biopic
hits Cinemas on July 21st Cruz's dead
reckoning rushes into Cinemas on July
12th giving the actor just over a week
to Showcase his film in the world's
preferred premium format Puck says that
Tom Cruise has been complaining about
Mission impossible's short IMAX window
to Paramount to Executives and others
well Christopher Nolan is arguably the
IMAX format's number one poster child
Cruz is also advocated for it several of
the actors films have been shown in IMAX
including last year's top gun Maverick
which made over 100 million dollars in
that format alone I'm access Crews to
thank as well as Maverick made the
company a solid chunk of change during a
key fiscal quarter in 2022 per variety
unfortunately it looks like Cruz don't
get a hold of Nolan's iMac screens as
Universal Pictures the studio behind
Oppenheimer locked them down all the way
back when the World War II Epic was
dated the possibility of a compromise
being reached doesn't seem likely
Oppenheimer holds all IMAX screens in
North America in certain territories for
three weeks this is Cruz we're talking
about Hollywood's last great star who
never goes down without a fight the
actor is focusing on securing as many
plf or premium large format screens that
aren't IMAX Cruz has been showing dead
reckoning part 1 to exhibitors with the
hopes that they'll screen his flick
instead of Oppenheimer or Barbie which
opens on the same day as Nolan's latest
to show how serious he is Cruz has been
personally calling exhibitors and execs
pitching why dead reckoning is a better
bet for them than Barbie or Oppenheimer
Tom Cruise is going even a step further
he's reportedly told his summer box
office adversaries that it's a smart
idea for them to give up their plf
screens or move their release dates of
course this won't happen which is why
all eyes are on the summer box office
champion of 2023 both June and July are
filled to the brim with tent poles and
Blockbusters the sheer amount of
back-to-back releases is astounding and
in a way they're all cannibalizing one
another by not giving each other enough
space should Crews know better if he was
willing to sit on top gun Maverick for
over two years he has the ability to be
flexible with dead reckoning's release
date the month of August is pretty much
clear but it's too little too late and
Cruz probably knows that while it
boasted a solid opening Maverick was a
film that succeeded because of its legs
not its debut dead reckoning will
probably be another Smash Hit for
cruising company which is why it's
important to think long term once I've
surrounding Barbie and Oppenheimer dies
down it's possible that dead reckoning
emerges as a summer fixture quarantine
repeat viewings and legs that are
comparable to Maverick as for Cruz's
battle to secure as many PLS screens as
possible only time will tell if he
succeeds
foreign